[Music]
welcome back to after record where we
talk about whatever
we want you got some progress yeah
uh we got cat back today cat i'm so
sad that you didn't i didn't know oh
guys cut you off what's up okay
i'm so sad that i didn't know that
you're in maui when you're actually a
maui because i have so many things
for you to try there oh my god my trip
to maui was
a hot ass mess when did you go to maui i
went to maui about
two weeks ago when we got there we were
so excited and we went through all the
covid protocols it was great and then
the day after we arrived we had the road
to hana
and i had never been on the road to hana
before but my boyfriend has what is that
it's like this uh you're basically
driving around the island and you're
seeing
all of the views from the mountaintop
and then you stop by different spots to
do
hikes and this was the trip i realized
i'm not
an outdoorsy person and that was like
the day
and i always find out like what happened
well first and foremost i am not built
for it because i got carsick right away
oh no and so i was like closing my eyes
trying not to throw up and then his
first time you got carsick like no i
usually get carsick but i didn't know
this is what the road to hana was i
didn't know it was like winding up a
mountain
it's windy as hell and it's kind of
scary and you're like on the side of the
mountain where like you see the ocean
one wrong turn you're dead yeah it
almost feels like there's a one way and
then like you gotta
one person has to park they get squeezed
if it's going like that it's better
if you're driving not riding the car yes
you think you would have had a better
time
driving the car then probably or your
boyfriend just looks at driving
uh it could be both on that's impossible
it's impossible white men are really
good at driving you
get carsick in the car it's always the
women's it's the passenger's fault
it's the passenger's followers it is you
gotta take the drama mean you gotta have
the ginger ale
you gotta be ready tell them yeah i
don't know about that but
he's full of [ __ ] but yeah but my
boyfriend has this thing where if i'm
not talking to him he thinks i'm mad at
him
and so i would close my eyes and try to
like focus on something
else so i don't throw up and for i'd say
three hours he would try to say like hi
do you like it it's pretty isn't it and
he's just like
like destroyed because he thinks i'm mad
at him for some reason he should have
just vomited and in his head
we were fighting for three hours oh yeah
that's kind of [ __ ] up cat that's what
that's what he told me too
and i told him shut up stop being a
[ __ ] yeah stop being a little bit yeah
good yeah
we got to the city of hana which is like
a very small
con like countryside town and no one
really
actually stays the night people do the
road and then they drive back so it's
like a
one full day excursion of hiking views
and then you get banana bread on the way
isn't that car sickness both ways then
yes did you throw up the banana bread uh
no
very close i almost threw up seeing the
porta potty i had to
use because he wanted me to pee on the
side of the road
but it's like i'm not gonna flash a
bunch of strangers my [ __ ]
at least for free yeah yeah they gotta
pay for that you gotta pay for that yeah
that's an exclusive
link right here it did change after all
that so she knows there's value in that
there's value to everything
yeah i was giving it away for free for a
way too long on the
other side of the car instead of on the
main street yeah
facing the traffic have you thought
about that why are you so dumb
because i'm shy like my bladder is shy
it just doesn't want to like release
silly
no like i can't i physically travel
constipation yes
oh my god i could not [ __ ] for four days
yeah wow a lot of people have that
what do you think the cause of that is
they're in flight or fight mode
they've never done a talent show what is
that is that fight or flight if you're
holding oh you're just you're just uh
you're just
you're just in fear mode so like you're
like you're like on adrenaline alert
because
travel makes people anxious yeah even
if they don't if they're unaware of how
anxious they are
like and then that just makes them
constipated but also the food too i
could be at her [ __ ] resort relaxing
with drinks and stuff like half
drunk but i'm still like you're full of
[ __ ] [ __ ] still and i'm like oh [ __ ] i
guess i'm anxious still but i'm like
we're just on a resort why am i anxious
i'm [ __ ] my way like airport airport
in the air airport hotel i'm like
[ __ ] the whole way there
too relaxed yeah maybe go [ __ ] at food
land for a sec
and then on the road no that's not loose
she knows what's up it's tight it's
super tight it's tight my friend rather
[ __ ] in nature than inside of a public
bathroom
and he can't wait he always has a roll
of toilet paper we go hiking he can't
get
comfortable yeah we were snowboarding
and he couldn't wait
to [ __ ] like on snow like while we're
snowboarding he'll pull over to the side
and go where all the trees are and take
a [ __ ] there he's washing his hands in
the bathroom he's washing his hands his
bathroom he goes
oh [ __ ] i have diarrhea let's get on the
ski lift
no joke he was like we need to hurry up
and go on a run because i need to call
the bathroom
why is he like that so did you do any
outdoor stuff when you're on when you
went to the destination well the first
day we went the majority of the hikes we
couldn't do because it was raining so we
were kind of like
in a shitty situation why because it's
like flooding down the trail yeah
so everyone was eating [ __ ] you would
see like a bunch of tourists on the side
who just finished the hike and they're
covered in mud they have scrapes
everywhere oh damn
and so he was disappointed because he
like built up this idea of
this is gonna be great it's gonna be
beautiful but then it's raining
i have a like motion sickness i can't
[ __ ] or like piss on the side of the
road like he thought i was going to be
able to
and you're mad at him too and apparently
worked for three hours
so he had such a horrible time and all
the food trucks on like the way
to the final hike that everyone does
we're closed down because of coven
and so we couldn't really even like get
food on the way we didn't have starving
you're hangry
yeah korean i just want to get to like a
toilet that's all i really wanted
to throw up there's still toilets there
i wanted to do both there are no
toilets and the one toilet i found made
me regret not going on the side of the
road
oh it's the one with all the colors in
it the potty
wear what you know some porta potties
have every shade of brown you've ever
seen yeah
i always tell myself i don't want to
look but you have to
look at the [ __ ] look this one the
whole for the toilet was so big i had no
like choice but to look and i could see
five different people [ __ ] in there
yeah like it's different those are good
numbers those are good numbers like it's
going up and down like i am motion sick
and
the last thing i want to see is five
different pieces of [ __ ] in here yeah
what was your favorite
or were they running there were it
seemed like two were runny because they
were different colors so i assume it was
from different people
there's like the third one was very
solid another one was kind of soft
so i was like okay and then the last one
i was just like this is a child this has
to be a child
because it was like that like you know
when kids get kind of sick and they have
like a
greenish like yellow drinking milk all
day
yeah i was just like this is a child
[ __ ] i don't know how it got in here but
it's a child's [ __ ]
[Music]
so there's that other than that it was
good we ate food my boyfriend
uh got food poisoning but luckily he
didn't get food poisoning
and have to [ __ ] on the flight home or
on
the car ride back to the resort so it
got like
food poisoning was it the shits it was
the one where you didn't know it was
coming like he let out a fart and he
happened to be on the toilet and he said
it just went
wow what did he eat i think he had like
a
pork sits weird in his stomach so he
tried some kahlua pork and then
i think that's what it was he's gonna
hate that i'm talking about this he's
such like a
he's not like prissy but like he's very
like i don't like people knowing about
stuff like this
oh okay wait that's who
he has boundaries he's like i'm a porn
star
but wait i draw the line when it comes
to my poo poo
your boyfriend's a porn star he used to
do porn yeah because uh before
he was with me he was dating a porn star
and they used to do
porn together during the pandemic and
porn couple vloggers
yeah we're in couple vloggers yeah it's
good content
and but he's like such a prude so funny
really
yeah out of the both of us he's the
fruit that's so
[ __ ] funny well some people have
their own boundaries right i guess
yeah being poop shy is a normal thing
though is it you know yeah
some people some people can't [ __ ] in
public restrooms yeah animals are poop
shy
yeah if they've ever seen an animal poop
shy it's like dogs and cats like they
like going off to like
i don't know the corners of the world i
got mine
taken away maybe because of my mom
because she's never been poop shy
and she could [ __ ] anywhere you took
mine away i took doors away
so i think i'm kind of happy i'm glad i
was raised by my mom because she
always has because she has no shame yeah
cause like she has diarrhea like
every day i don't know why that's not
good though that's not good
every day like we'll talk about that
later like she's like this is why i
became vegetarian because that helped me
because it's better for my gut but after
vegetarian food she has diarrhea still
and then she she lives [ __ ] high
anxiety at a shell gas station anywhere
flight she's a fighter flight model yeah
she's fighting she could squat on the
toilet or
she could if the toilet seat's broken
you got to stop saying she squats on the
toilet she does not [ __ ] squat on the
toilet he always says that she does this
[ __ ] and i've taken a [ __ ] with not with
her but like
he swears in his mind america she does
that all the time because the gas
station toilets are nasty hey some
people be [ __ ] like that bro i did
that
up until i was 12. today's video is
brought to you
by feels cbd isn't about what you feel
it's about what you do not feel such as
lately i've been training jiu-jitsu it's
been pretty crazy man
i haven't done it since like what when
we did mma how many years ago was that
that's like almost a decade or something
right 10 15 years ago
but if you remember doing those it's
like a
crazy adrenaline rush and when you're
done
you're just like your [ __ ] body
shaking yeah cuz you just fought someone
pretty much
yeah and i take night classes oh yeah so
man when i'm done it's already like
eight or nine
right and i'm trying to be a grandpa get
my rest but i'm
in bed till like midnight just shaking
like this
so now i have this whole process um i
just get some
field cbd and i make this tumeric tea
and then i drop a few drops get in my
robe after a shower i just [ __ ] sip
on that
and i have a whole system of relaxation
yeah
and it actually gets me into this
chill space where i calm down way
freaking quicker
and then i knock the hell out like a
little baby that's dope because that's
what feels is made for it's help reduce
stress
a little bit anxiety pain management has
lots of benefits
and if this is your first time trying
cbd they even have a hotline that can
walk you through it all you have to do
is put a couple drops underneath your
tongue or in a drink like the way
joe does and you can feel relaxed and
sleep better and helps you get over some
of the
angsty feelings that you might have and
what's really dope is right now if you
go to feels.com
off the record you will get 50
off your first order plus free shipping
when you become a member and that's
feels f e
a l s dot com slash off the record to
get 50
off your first order plus free shipping
when you become a member
see andrew houston right from asia
that's just like what my
uh parents used to tell me like if
you're constipated as a kid they would
tell me to like
squat because that's just naturally how
like it goes down and that's how like
they [ __ ] in asia yeah
and so up until i was 12 like i used a
[ __ ] like that and i used to never [ __ ]
in public restrooms
because you knew it was weird or yeah
and then one day i was like wait so if i
have to [ __ ] at school
i have to take off like my my entire
pants and like hop on do i keep my shoes
on do i keep it off
and that's when i realized not everybody
squats on the toilet when they [ __ ]
so you did that since a kid like a cat
yes but i never had [ __ ] in public
so i only [ __ ] in the comfort of my home
and i thought that was normal you went
through like kindergarten to sixth grade
without ever
[ __ ] in school at school yeah okay
you always [ __ ] in the morning
in the morning uh shy i was always very
irregular but i never had to [ __ ] at
school
it just like comes and goes if i'm not
at school i know i'll [ __ ] i just don't
know when
i just know i won't [ __ ] while i'm in
school i just didn't like how there were
no doors at our back
wait there's no doors no wait why are
there no doors
was there an adult mail in there because
that's no it was never
doors like if you go to any la
public school bathroom if you go to all
the stalls
none of them have the guy yeah the guy
ones yeah how do you take a [ __ ]
you just [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah and you don't even have toilet
paper you have the the paper that they
used to for the donuts like the donuts
yeah that's right it's just she wears up
donut wax paper
i'm like why the [ __ ] do you have this
it's always flooded it's always full of
parchment paper yeah
and there's never any [ __ ] door dog
so everyone went to the nurse's bathroom
when they needed to take yo in our high
school
if like any nobody would [ __ ] at our
high school because
we all the doors are broken kind of like
what joe was saying they had physical
doors but they wouldn't latch no i said
some of them even had doors yeah
they didn't even have hinges my
elementary school was like that but then
at any point in time like a group of
guys would just go inside
and just like at my high school they
would like shoot dice
they would [ __ ] just do like crazy
[ __ ] in the bathroom like some people
will fight
while you're talking [ __ ] yeah i mean
that makes sense dude
like they would they're like oh this
motherfucker's taking a [ __ ] and it's
like i gotta go man bro [ __ ] like they
would [ __ ] with you dude so everybody
would take a [ __ ] in my high school
that's crazy our bathrooms all had
stalls
and then we had different body splash
things and we had like one
yeah we had like tourist secrets no i'm
kidding
you had a maid
condoms and [ __ ] you're like this is
elementary school what the [ __ ] for sure
you got to be safe you're gonna do you
gotta be safe
and pads like this just tic tacs breath
man
what was the positive thing about mommy
though because i just hear all that
that's like that's my second home man
you guys say something great about it
food was great i will say food was great
people were amazing what was your
favorite food
uh i ate my weight in banana bread the
entire time
wow every single day i loaf to myself
that would explain the constipation
though
honestly but it's banana is there fiber
i thought banana yeah isn't it supposed
to be too much fiber it could
actually make you constipated really
yeah i don't know who told me this but
i took it as fact when they told me i
was like oh bananas make you constipated
mustard
that's true but yeah i get constipated
in hawaii all the time
what about our last trip too much food
yeah i just drink too much food
eat too much food and then like and it
doesn't release naturally it just
doesn't really like we got too much [ __ ]
in here yeah you gotta eat more shaved
ice bro push everything down what
that's [ __ ] nah it's true so the
syrups and the corns you know the corn
syrup helps push
all the way through do you feel heavier
or like more bloated if you don't poop
for a future yeah
it feels weird yeah and i get like i get
self-conscious at the beach too so like
i know i have like that bloated like
belly look that lower belly like
bloatish yeah i was like oh god
you're just going you're swimming you're
like yeah maybe it'd be a good idea to
really sit out here
now
hey
that's no guarantee your shit's gonna be
the five different colors she saw
because it's like multiple days of [ __ ]
stacked in there
but you're trash but i vomited it in the
ocean
[ __ ] in the ocean bro why are you
[ __ ] the ocean no because she
cause she remembers my stories better
than i do because [ __ ] just happens and
it's not a big deal
yeah but i kind of i remember there's a
time where i told you you were in hawaii
and i [ __ ] in the ocean and then i was
like
oh [ __ ] there's no toilet paper but i'm
like it's fine because it's water so i
just stuck my finger on my butt i just
went
i don't think
because i remember i honestly remember
having my swimming trunks at my knees
and treading water like this oh so you
weren't standing you were like
treading and [ __ ] 15 feet
oh you're [ __ ] disgusting give me the
snorkel okay i think you remember that
i think only only only in emergencies
bro
you get to [ __ ] in the ocean three times
in your life that's it why three
that's it why three because three
different emergencies
not the people you're the [ __ ] [ __ ]
generally you shouldn't have to
you probably shouldn't have to [ __ ] in
the ocean more than three sheets three
oceans
you are not a lot because if you're if
you're three you can stand that's where
the kids are you know
no matter any depths no matter what
depth so you could do it in a pool no no
three ocean ships
ocean chicken i'm curious you're all
like cricket dissolves like how quick
does it dissolve
and do fish come up and eat it i bet
fishy because i [ __ ] puked all over
and it brought so much
[Laughter]
i'm in the water yeah that i almost
[ __ ] died doing that [ __ ] that was
crazy
did your [ __ ] float when it hit i got
away as fast as i could
i just imagine like shit's just like
[ __ ] sitting there yeah they float
right
once so once the [ __ ] hits the water
yeah it's like
um you know what you do like alcohol
asking me if you don't remember now you
have [ __ ] all these vivid [ __ ]
images you talk about certain things it
comes back it comes back so you just
helped
trigger a great memory i remember all
the time when this will talk
i'm like oh yeah i did [ __ ] in the ocean
too like i remember
you know you know alka-seltzer when you
drop it in the water and there's fizzes
yeah
i remember looking back
outside
[Laughter]
i was like [ __ ] dolphin
what type of radioactive [ __ ] do you
have
i think the age-old question for me of
like why i got so curious about [ __ ]
is in the water right is will my [ __ ]
when it opens up
suck up water when it shoots it didn't i
thought it would it did it
it did it did it well it's not only one
way it's like you're
you're pushing something out so it's not
like yeah it goes like this it comes out
and then as soon as it's done it goes
yeah it's like a vacuum seal hey but you
guys aren't opening your [ __ ] wide
enough
what you're opening your [ __ ] wide
enough i'm sure open your [ __ ]
you guys don't practice this well that's
true because it's like farting in water
wait what garden water air doesn't i
mean water doesn't get inside
when you fart in the tub and because
it's only outgoing stuff
but i feel like you left your butthole
open and you're just if you want it what
do you
feel like you need to go to a doctor
yeah well if you could if you wanted to
i'm sure it would go back
up we're going to test it out we'll
figure it out i need to continue you
know we can get water in our vagina
if you can if you can physically open
your [ __ ] oh like you physically
like spread it i thought you were just
like bending over like so you're in the
ocean with your butt cheek spread
yeah if you just open it i'm sure water
would diffuse into your [ __ ]
this is the reason why they hate
tourists in hawaii
because we're [ __ ] in the water well
this guy is
the only one you just granted his three
[ __ ] wishes bro so
in your lifetime in your lifetime it's
good you shouldn't have to use those
though
you should only have one to two at most
if you have three if you use up your
throat
i think you should in the ocean you
gotta figure some [ __ ] out why is warm
you gotta wear a diaper bro like
why is it very warm it's just different
so like when i was
doing the actual [ __ ] action i did
pull my butt cheeks apart because i
don't want to smear
oh doing that part hey he's thinking
ahead no but that part
that part is true because if have you
ever
tried [ __ ] while going like
because if i don't have my hands i'm not
always above water
so i have to have the snorkeling so i
have to go
all the people spreading and [ __ ]
but you're training without your hands
you're trying just with your phone i do
have my
uh fins on too so it does help fighting
yeah oh wow
you know the three people that are
watching like the three people that can
relate to this
are just like oh yeah that's exactly the
process when you [ __ ] like
michael phelps the greats he's [ __ ] in
the pool for sure kelly slater
probably kelly slater i don't know
another third water guy
ryan lochte that guy for sure shits in
the water
he's shitty he's done more than three
water polo guys
water polo guys
[Music]
you